le festival de cannes attire chaque
année douze mille professionnels du
cinéma ils sont réalisateurs producteurs
acteurs et même exploitant de salles par
mieux égale pineau le responsable du
grenier à sel de trappes vient depuis
une dizaine d'années sur la croisette
est l'occasion pour lui de faire des
rencontres et de voir des films beaucoup
de films trois à cinq projections par
jour est de dénicher quelques bonnes
idées
et puis l'eau vous êtes présents ici à
cannes pour ce festival depuis le
dimanche 6 mais dites moi à quoi
ressemblent vos journées sur place en a
plusieurs types de journée puisque les
premiers jours sont consacrés aux
rencontres aux réunions du réseau art et
essai donc on a beaucoup d'airness le
général les réunions des avec toutes les
institutions
on voit beaucoup de films aussi ça c'est
les premiers jours et ensuite le
festival commence il a commencé cette
année le mardi soir s'est décalé par
rapport aux années précédentes
et là maintenant le festival c'est comme
chaque festivalier on essaie d'avoir le
plus de films possible donc on fait
beaucoup là que beaucoup beaucoup la
queue on mange quand on peut on marche
on traverse la ville dans tous les sens
l'intérêt ce but pour pour moi c'est
c'est d'aller voir le maximum de films
de rencontrer aussi maximum de gens et
on est vraiment dans le monde entier du
cinéma est réunie à cannes en ce moment
et c'est le moment pour rencontrer les
distributeurs les institutions les
collègues faire des réunions ça fait une
dizaine d'années que vous venez ici sur
place
en tant que passionné de cinéma de deux
responsables de salles comme le grenier
à sel de trappes pourquoi il faut être
ici pourquoi c c'est le lieu où il faut
être
cannes c'est un endroit où il ya
beaucoup de décisions qui sont prises il
ya beaucoup d'annoncés qui sont faites
aussi par par le tas le cnc
les dracs et les distributeurs donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sait si d'ici
qui s'annonce ici et c'est aussi le
moment pour rencontrer les collègues
connaître les problèmes des autres de
savoir quelle solution qu'ils ont
trouvée au problème qu'on peut avoir un
nouveau 6 et aussi beaucoup voir les
films parce que en tant que
programmateur
ça me permet de voir très en avance
certains films qui viendront
certainement certains très très
important pour pour l'année je faisais
beaucoup vous avez vu beaucoup de films
ici on va pas vous demander les coups de
coeur il faut il faut digérer tout ça
mais est-ce que ça va vous servir dans
la préparation de la programmation au
grenier à sel peut être des projections
qui seront proposés au grenier à sel
pour moi ça a aimé dans le grenier à sel
attraper le programmation
très art et essai et tous les films du
festival sont son arrêt c'est donc donc
je fais mon choix dedans ça me permet de
les connaître à l'avance de pouvoir en
parler mieux aussi
et ça me permet de savoir de fermer
programme est
de la semaine de l'année et de
éventuellement d'anticiper vraiment s'il
ya une animation à faire s'il ya un coup
de coeur s'il ya une amie à quelqu'un
que je peux essayer d'inviter et puis
mon pas se mentir il fait beau ça change
un petit peu de la région parisienne
donc on se ressource aussi pas mal merci
galuppi no mercy
[Musique]
chaque jour coup de projecteur sur un
film financé par la région ile-de-france
d'état aux réalisé par le chinois wang
bing fait partie de la sélection
officielle dans la catégorie des séances
spéciales
un documentaire de plus de 8 heures qui
aborde le destin tragique de milliers de
prisonniers morts dans des camps de
rééducation dans le nord de la chine il
ya 60 ans
le film est parti à la rencontre des
survivants et proches tiennent 78 c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui rendez-vous dès
demain pour rencontrer de nouveaux
festivaliers yvelinois
[Musique]